Alright.
I need to think about how many rounds of divisions I'll have. I know my cells
are going to replicate over one day. One day is 24 hours. I know my cell divides
every 2 hours, so I can take 24 hours and divide it by 2 hours, that'll give me
12. This is the number of rounds of division I'll have. My cells are quadrupling
each time after a round of division. I went from one cell to four cells. So
remember, this cell would split into four more cells. This one would, too. And
this one would, too. And so, would this last one. I went from 1, to 4, to 16.
I'm quadrupling the number of cells I have. So my base should be 4, and I have
12 rounds of division, 4 to the 12th. And I get an answer of 16,777,216. That's
a ton of cells. We are going to figure out an easier way to write this number in
the next section. Great job for now if you got that right.